i've been reviewing apple's ipad pro
ever since their controversial
what's a computer ad in 2017 which
basically sparked years of
disappointment
in the ipad pro's very limiting software
especially after the 2018 ipad pro got a
massive redesign
and an extremely powerful a12x chip and
in my review of that 11 inch ipad pro
over two and a half years ago
i said these words apple may continue
adding computer-like features here and
there but the ipad pro will never be a
true laptop replacement
until apple wants it to be and now here
we are in 2021
with the m1 ipad pro that we've had our
hands on for the past three weeks
and the story's basically the same the
performance of this new ipad pro
is absolutely mind-boggling especially
when you compare it to the very best
tablets on the market
they literally don't stand a chance and
they won't
for years but the problem comes when the
ipad os software is so
limited that you literally cannot take
advantage of
all of that performance and with the
newly released ipad os 15
people are so upset and disappointed
that they are literally
returning their new m1 ipad pros
because apple didn't add the
computer-like features
that everyone was waiting for and in my
personal opinion
i think a lot of people are overreacting
at least for the 11 inch ipad pro which
i'm reviewing in
this video and i'll explain my reasoning
in just a minute but first i want to
talk about
why people are so upset and to be honest
it's kind of apple's fault they
basically baited everyone into having
massive expectations for ipad os 15
by first of all putting the exact same
chip
from the incredible new m1 max into the
ipad pro
as well as allowing you to get up to 16
gigabytes of ram
which was unheard of on an ipad pro
since the previous model
only had 6 gigs and as we all recently
found out
the previous ipad os 14 software
wouldn't even allow apps to use
more than 5 gigabytes of that 16 gig
limit on the new ipad pro
and we proved this in our 8 gigabyte
versus 16 gig
ipad pro comparison video where there
were basically
no differences in the worst part is that
the previous a12z ipad pro
was still overpowered for ipad os 14.
so the fact that apple gave the new
model the m1 chip
with up to 16 gigs of ram basically
baited everyone into thinking that apple
was gonna finally turn
the ipad pro into a real computer
replacement
by removing artificial software
limitations and adding pro apps like
final cut and logic
but of course that didn't happen so
here's the main question we need to
answer
why did apple still end up putting the
crazy m1 chip
into the ipad pro if they didn't have
plans to completely
revolutionize the software well first of
all
not everyone realizes this but the a12z
chip from the previous ipad pro
had almost the same exact chip layout as
the m1
four performance cores four efficiency
cores
eight graphics cores and a neural engine
so in reality
the m1 chip isn't that groundbreaking or
special
it's basically just a new version of the
a12z
except that it's built on tsmc's more
efficient five nanometer
transistors instead of the old seven
nanometer ones
so if you think about it apple could
have easily gone with their previous
trend
and named the chip the a14x like
everyone is expecting them to
and we even expected the a14x and the m1
to have basically the same performance
since they would have had
the same layout essentially the same
chip so here's the real question that we
have to answer
why did apple choose to ditch the a14x
trend
and literally just take the m1 chip out
of the mac
and throw it into the ipad pro well it
actually makes much more sense than you
think
at least for apple first of all the m1
chip is basically the mascot or the
symbol of the apple silicon transition
since they've literally packed that chip
into half of their entire mac lineup so
apple's goal
is to essentially make the m1 chip go
viral so that their apple silicon
transition goes viral
and what better way to do that is to
stick the m1 and yet another popular
apple product
reason number two is that the m1 chip
carries an outstanding reputation
among the mac crowd for being incredibly
powerful
while using very little power so having
that chip
in the ipad pro makes it seem a whole
lot more pro
than ever before reason number three is
that since the m1 chip already comes
with a thunderbolt
controller built in it automatically
added support
for the ipad pro's new thunderbolt port
yet again
making it seem much more pro and reason
number four is that believe it or not
the m1 chip is actually much cheaper per
unit
than if apple made a slightly different
a14x chip
just for the ipad pro because the m1 is
literally the only option for the new
macbook air
macbook pro mac mini 24 inch imac
and the ipad pro apple can mass
manufacture that one chip
and save a ton of cash compared to if
they made a specific chip
just for the ipad pro which would take a
lot of extra r d
so basically putting the m1 chip in this
ipad
made absolutely the most financial sense
for apple
but the problem is that it caused
extremely high
expectations and a lot of people were
let down
even to the point of returning their
ipad pros
and don't get me wrong i'm not blaming
you for having huge
expectations because apple kind of put
themselves in a box
and if you want to find out how apple
did that click the subscribe button
below
because max is gonna go in depth with
apple's dilemma
and his 12.9 inch m1 ipad pro review
going up tomorrow but for this review
i'm gonna look at the 11 inch model
for what it truly is the truth is that
the 11 inch m1 ipad pro for 800
is a much better value than the previous
ipad pro
which we already were recommending
because of its exclusive features
compared to the lower end ipads in fact
we still recommended the a12z ipad pro
when the brand new 600 ipad air 4 came
out late last year
because in reality you truly did get a
lot for the extra 200
but now with the m1 ipad pro the list of
advantages over the air is so
huge that we literally told people not
to buy the ipad air
in our recent ipad buyers guide video
because at 600
it's simply too expensive for what you
get compared to spending
two hundred dollars more for the m1 pro
for example
the pro gets a 120 hertz pro motion
display
with 600 nits of brightness instead of
500
which allows it to support hdr video it
also gets
extra camera features including an
ultrawide camera on the back
a flash a lidar scanner for 3d modeling
and a much better 12 megapixel ultrawide
selfie camera
with the new center stage feature it
gets much better quad stereo speakers
instead of dual stereo on the air
it gets much better studio quality
microphones it gets optional 5g
connectivity
it gets the thunderbolt port compared to
a pretty limited
usb c port it gets much faster ssd
write speeds it gets 8 gigs of ram
instead of 4 on the air
it gets 128 gigs of storage instead of
64
and of course it gets the m1 chip
compared to the a14
on the air and taking a look at all of
the benchmarks that we ran
it's faster in everything including the
single core performance
which gives it a snappier web browsing
experience
it's also much faster in terms of
multi-core performance
and it was over twice as fast in terms
of real-world
graphics performance as well so the
point that i'm trying to make
is that if you get rid of all of those
high expectations
and just look at the m1 ipad pro
compared to the last one
it's definitely a nice improvement the
11 inch ipad pro is now further cemented
as the best tablet ever made with
performance that'll run even the best
apps that will be available
years from now and incredibly high
quality speakers and microphones
and the killer 120hz display even
without the mini led tech
and it's got the best stylus experience
you can get
with the apple pencil and the software
works
incredibly well even if it doesn't come
with the macbook replacing features
that we were all hoping for so i've
gotta say that this is one of the best
times to buy an ipad pro
because we've basically just reached the
peak of ipad hardware
and if by some chance apple decides to
fix the software issues
within the next couple of years or even
the next few years
the m1 ipad pro will be ready for it and
the reason i say it's reached peak
hardware is because the m1 chip is so
powerful
that it's hitting the limits of the thin
ipad pro's
passive cooling system so when the next
ipad pro comes out
probably in the fall of 2022 it'll
likely get the m2 chip
which honestly won't be that big of an
improvement and as far as everything
else like the design
face id all of the cameras the speakers
the microphones the thunderbolt port the
keyboard
case support with the smart connector
all of the magnets
and everything else that has to do with
hardware they've basically all reached
their peak and they make using the ipad
pro as a tablet
the best experience out there in terms
of everything from media consumption
note-taking drawing gaming and common
computer use
the only issue is that the 2018 ipad pro
was so far ahead of its time that even
today
it checks all of those boxes not quite
as well as the new m1 model
but it still does so if you own a 2018
or 2020 ipad pro
don't bother upgrading unless you're
doing something specific
that you think would make a big
difference for you on the new m1 ipad
pro
like for example high end gaming since
the m1 chip stays incredibly cool
compared to the a12 z chip which
overheats
like crazy and gentian impact or maybe
you want to take advantage of the
thunderbolt porn
like how we were able to hook up this
owc thunderbolt dock
meant for m1 max which basically turns
one thunderbolt port into
three and as you can see it actually
works great on the new ipad pro
but other than those couple of
improvements the new m1 ipad pro
isn't really that groundbreaking or
different
compared to the 2018 and 2020 models and
with that said there is actually one
piece of hardware on the 11 inch m1 ipad
pro
that hasn't yet reached its peak and
that is of course
the regular lcd display compared to the
12.9 inch model's mini led
and in my personal opinion i think apple
is going to give
that new display to the 11 ipad pro next
year
so they'll have a good excuse to bump up
the base price by 100 bucks
to 900 for the base model so if you
don't already have a 2018 or newer ipad
pro
and you're thinking of buying the new m1
you basically have
two options you can wait a full year and
a half with the hopes of getting that
mini led display
on the 11 inch model for probably nine
hundred dollars
or you can buy the current model right
now for 800 bucks
and enjoy it for the entire time that
you would have otherwise been waiting
but either way the m1 ipad pro is
definitely the best tablet in the world
with hardware that's so good that it's
basically future proof
so if apple ever does fix the software
and make it more of a laptop replacement
you'll be ready for it but as it stands
today ipad os 15 is extremely
disappointing compared to how good the
ipad pro's hardware
is and that's exactly what max is going
to talk about
and his review of the 12.9 inch mini led
model
so if you're not already subscribed
click that circle above so you don't
miss out on his review
so thanks for watching and we'll see you
in tomorrow's video